lieber Tom oh wir haben uns was überlegt
nämlich ganz liebe Fragen an dich und
ganz gemeine du kannst selber
entscheiden die roten sind richtig
gemein ja wir haben es versucht doch ja
sind richtig gemein und die Grünen sind
total harmlos du kannst blind ziehen du
kannst alle ziehen du kannst ma ich will
natürlich eine gemeine ist okay gut gut
gut gut okay wie mach ich das auch genau
einfach abdrehen abdrehen so
okay
willst du immer so weiter prollen würde
ich sagen na ja okay es müssen ja nicht
nur prollige Filme sein aber ich würde
mich auf jeden Fall nicht dagegen
wehren man muss eben prollen mit Niveau
man muss eben es so gut machen dass es
nicht nur bescheuert bescheuert ist
sondern gut bescheuert ist das heißt
auch denjenigen der nicht nur auf dem
flach steht trifft oder abholt oder nur
die intelligenten stehen unsere
Botschaft ja die ganz klugen die
dazwischen die so ein bisschen klug sind
was ist sind am Arsch was ist die
Botschaft das verrate ich Dir nicht das
Mus okay ich bin noch nicht ganz
dahinter gekommen so jetzt habe ich ein
grünen das ist ja harmlos das ist
harmlos aber die sind auch schwierig zu
beantworten trotzdem Z schwiig zu
beantworten da wir noch mal sehen ja die
sind so bauchpinsel W hast es geschafft
so lange im harten Comedy Geschäft zu
überleben ja weil ich meine Sache sehr
ernsthaft betreibe ich bastele zu Hause
meine Sachen zusammen ich nehme mir me
Zeit ich bin nicht in jeder Comedyshow
und und Red irgendwas daher sondern ich
lasse Pausen in diesen Pausen bereite
ich Dinge vor schreibe die Tüf sie
zusammen auch wenn es manchmal wirklich
vielleicht für manche was hart rüber
kommt oder extrem bekloppt drüber kommt
ich mache es doch sehr genau zusammen
mit den Leuten die mir helfen
und darum weil wir das eben so genau
nehmen habe ich auch 20 Jahre
überlebt aber du hast hast kann man das
irgendwo lernen was hast du studiert
deutsche
Gründlichkeit was hast du studiert
Philosophie glaube ich Germanistik ist
das richtig das muss man aus mein Film
sofort
ersehen schaut euch die super Bullen an
und dann wisst ihr wovon ich rede ich
habe eine hundsgemeine Frage an mich für
die ich Christoph gleich wahrscheinlich
verprügeln werde die ich jetzt wieder
aufmache ja ja ja das ist ja schon mal
fast passiert ich sag Tom warum bist du
so ein schöner sensibler und
wundervoller
Mensch ich möchte hier zu sagen dass ich
Moment aber gar nicht sprechen möchte es
ist einfach oh ich habe mich verlesen
hast du den Gag mit dem betonplatt in
dem Hund von John cle geklaut oder
gekauft was für G was Beton ich hat so
ein DJ nein es ist wirklich wahr es ist
ein Ding was wirklich inspiriert war
durch diesen Film weil ich ihn so liebe
und ein Fisch namens Wander und ich habe
gesagt das ist eine omage an Fisch
namens wander es ist nicht geklaut ist
eine omage so sagt man das wenn man was
klaut omage okay sehr schön noch weiter
direkt die gemein da kommt die schönsten
am Schluss ihr wollt ja so und so nur
die gemeinen hören ne natürlich die sind
am am spannendsten ihr wollt ja hören
dass das saug gemacht wäre und nicht
wäre und alles auseinander nehmen woher
nimmst du die vielen Ideen das ist ja
gar nicht gemein das ist ja grün ach das
ist ja grün die roten W nimst du die
vielen Ideen also sie werden wirklich
erarbeitet man man man sitzt an dem
Tisch und schwitzt und denkt wirklich
nach und kriegt irgendwann
Rückenschmerzen wie gesagt es ist
einfach ein hartes gesch Idee lernt was
vernünftiges macht nicht das was ich tue
so okay also die roten müssen
sein da zermn wir uns immer das Z rot
war gemein ja auf jeden Fall rot ist
gemein grün
ist
okay
warum immer Brasilianerinnen na ja das
ist ja nicht gemeint es hat
brasilianerinen in der Tat in meinem
Leben gegeben das ist richtig vi mehr
als andere
das nicht viel ist übertrieben aber ich
sage mal ich bin vielleicht manchmal
auch mit der Brasilianer gesehen worden
mit der ich gar nichts hatte und der
Rückschluss war Direktor so sagen das
Politiker wenn man solche Fragen stellt
ja ich bin definitiv mit einer
Brasilianer be freundet und wir sind
zusammen und
warum hat sich das so ergeben ähm ja ich
würde mal sagen die Lebensfreude meine
Freundin ist auch sehr hübsch das sage
ich auch ne und
sehr weiblich aber ich sag mal es müssen
keine Brasilianer sein ich war ja auch
vier Jahr mit der Deutschen verheiratet
und wir haben es toll verstanden
eigentlich und
es ist auch nicht so dass die
Brasilianern alle
schöner werden als die Deutschen dieses
Gerücht das stimmt ja gar nicht also
meine ist wirklich eine toll aussehende
Frau ist ja klar normal ne gucke ich
schon nach ich bin nicht doof aber so im
allgemeinen wenn du jetzt durch Rio
gehst das ist ja alles Show ne die Leute
kennen ja hier nur die sber
Girls die deutschen Mädels im Schnitt
sind die Deutschen medals schlagen Sie
die die deutschen MS schlagen ehlich das
glaube ich nicht ehrlich oh 100 pro aber
nicht an Temperament das die
S anderes aber wollte ich trotzdem
ansprechen wahnsinnig temperamentvoll
bevor du diese haben n so Frage da
beantwortet oder sehr Temperament voll
im allgemeinen schon also solltest nicht
unbedingt den Krieg unnötig beginnen nur
mit gutem Grund okay GU also meine
Freundin ist
sehr gutmütiger Menschen lieb aber ich
kann ich auch Feuerball verwandeln okay
wie viel Geschir habt ihr schon
zdeppert ein paar Gläser waren es glaube
ich es geht gerade noch ne okay aber mir
hat auch schon mal eine deutsche Teller
um die Ohren geschmissen so ist es nicht
okay also du hast das liegt an mir dass
ich schrecklich bin ja so wie schaffst
du es immer so ausgeglichen zu
sein i love this solche Fragen liebe ich
ich weiß es gar nicht wie ich das
schaffe
ich würde mal so sagen
ähm ich möchte einfach dass meine Umwelt
so unglaublich gut geht dass ich alle
anderen Gefühle in mir beherrsche und
immer so ausgeglichen bin und dass alle
mich nett finden und das das Leben
wunderschön ist
m nein ich weiß auch nicht ich bin
einfach nicht immer ausgeglichen morgens
ist nicht bin ich bin überhaupt gar
nicht immer ausgeglichen ist auch eine
Unterstellung ich ich bin sagen mal bei
wenn ich mit Menschen locker rede dann
aber ich bin es wirklich definitiv nicht
ich bin noch wie gesagt vormittags
vergeses so willst du nicht endlich mal
niveauolle Unterhaltung machen schon
wieder dieser Irrtum ich mache
niveauolle ich ma schwachse mit Niveau
und das wollt ihr nicht begreifen ne die
Sprache man sagt wie sagt man
immer der Ton macht die Musik sagt man
immer weil ich oft ein rauen Ton hab
auch ein gernman unflättigen auch manch
mal die Figuren von
mir niveaoses sagen glaubt man im
Rückschluss alles W niveolos oder auch
man würde doch über elbandi würde man
sagen dass an elbandi Serie niveos ist
würde man nicht sagen weil das von
Amerikaner ist wenn es ein deutscher
macht denkt man jetzt muss es aber so
sein ist Quatsch unsere Folgen sind noch
sauberer gemacht und geschrieben als von
albandi ich bin jetzt mal ganz
selbstbewusst und unverschämt so nein
das muss auch sagen Boulevard ist
wahnsinnig schwierig und dazu wir haben
du wirst es nicht Times Magazine habe
ich eine eine eine Eloge bekommen nein
für ausgerechnet für mein Film Siegfried
ich ich finde die superbllen hätten ih
noch mehr verdient aber das kommt noch
vielleicht ja eine Eloge merkt euch das
merkt es euch ein schreibt euch hinter
die das ist eine unglaubliche lobesne
eine unglaubliche lobesimne das heißt
auf deutsch ich ich bin die die die Amis
wissen bescheid ich bin super voll super
was macht dich so
populär das eine schöne letzte Frage ich
liebe sie was
mach love love
so
love was macht mich so populär ich weiß
nicht ich bin ein Volk ich gehe gezielt
darauf
den Leuten Freude und Spaß zu machen und
das ohne Umschweife
und es ist natürlich nach all Jahren ist
es natürlich treibt es mir die tränen
die Augen wenn ich sehe dass das doch
angekommen ist und ich solche Fragen
beantworten darf super vielen Dank und
wahnsinnigen Erfolg mit den superbollen
ja danke schön können wir
gebrauchen